لذلك الدكتور كولين كيلي معنا الآن
أستاذ مشارك في
قسم الطب بجامعة إيموري ، صباح الخير
لك يا
دكتور ، من الجيد جدًا أن تكون معنا ،
أريد أن أقفز من النقطة التي كان
يتحدث عنها فيما يتعلق
باللقاحات وأقول ذلك لأن نيويورك
تشير الأوقات هذا الصباح إلى أن
الأشخاص يواجهون مشاكل في الحصول على
جرعتهم الثانية ، ونعلم في هامبشاير الجديدة وواشنطن
وكونيكتيكت
تحديدًا أن هناك بعض الأشخاص الذين
يعانون بالفعل من بعض الإحباطات هنا ، حيث
قام القرص المضغوط الذي أعرفه
بتمديد تلك الفترة من 21 إلى 28
يومًا
بين  اللقطة الأولى والثانية
وقلنا أنه يمكنك الانتظار حتى ستة أسابيع ، ولكن
ما هي العواقب بالنسبة للأشخاص ، هل
نعرف ما هي النتيجة
إذا لم يحصلوا على جرعتهم خلال هذا
الإطار الزمني
جيدًا ، فهذا يثير القلق قليلاً
عندما  لا يمكنني الحصول على هذا
اللقاح في تلك الفترة الفاصلة التي تبلغ 21 يومًا لشركة
فايزر ، وهي فترة 28 يومًا لمودرن ،
لكنني أشجع الناس على عدم
القلق ، فمن المحتمل أن يكون هناك قدر كبير من
مساحة كبيرة للمناورة في الحصول على الجرعة الثانية
عدة أسابيع على الأقل وهذا هو السبب في
صدور قرص مضغوط وقال إن ستة أسابيع
ربما تكون على ما يرام
ليس لدينا البيانات العلمية
لهذه اللقاحات لدعم ذلك
تمامًا حتى الآن
ولكن أود أن أقول أن ما نعرفه  حول
اللقاحات الأخرى وإطالة هذه
الفواصل الزمنية
أمر جيد ويميل إلى أن يكون جيدًا
وأحيانًا أفضل عندما تقوم بتمديد
الفترة الفاصلة بين نظام جرعتين
للقاح ،
لذلك أود أن أقول الحصول على اللقاح
بأسرع ما يمكن ولكن لا داعي للذعر  إذا لم يكن
بالضبط
في الإطار الزمني الذي كنت
تتوقعه